on le surnomme spaceman et ça lui va à
merveille
béliers un excentrique comme il s'en
fait peu instruits je continuerai à qui
mieux mais les honneurs de notre
profondeur est à warwick en espèces mais
bélie c'est aussi une légende du
baseball majeur
un des rares lanceur gaucher à connaître
du succès au fenway park de boston avec
les reds à deux matchs des séries
mondiales
puis ce fut les expos
je lis
je tends
les besoins d'emprunt
je dois admettre que je prends en compte
un nombre comparable de belleville y est
un vrai bain en titre et anticonformiste
histoire at il faut pour kouassi gérante
se nomme les mais ça faisait de la bonne
copine journalistique à ses débuts avec
les expos sont fracassants notamment au
micro quand il y va de révélations
disons surprenante et des clans qui met
la marijuana
l'or est courte encore longtemps fin d
année ce sont des 10 ces scandales lundi
à 69 embellie règne toujours au
monticule
nous sommes au premier match des séries
de la ligue senior du vermont je prends
des sports excédé bélisle ans une courbe
à l'establishment et fait le saut en
politique il brigue le poste de
gouverneur du vermont sous la bannière
du parti de l'union libérale
l'ancien parti de bonus en deux
campagnes lancées vieira la recevoir le
maire de burlington n'est pas si surpris
et il insiste
bélie et coloré oui mais loin d'être fou
sa priorité pour le vermont
l'environnement mais attention délit
promet aussi d'éliminer la frontière
entre son et
et le québec il veut d'ailleurs que le
vermont adhère à l'assurance maladie de
la belle province et le candidat a une
autre idée ramener les expos en
diminuant les rays de tampa bay à
montréal c'est oublier exposé
montpellier capitale du vermont délivre
sa première apparition publique midi
tapant le candidat n'est pas arrivé son
organisateur de campagne et nerveux car
le forum de la commission sur les femmes
du vermont débute justement à midi à une
heure où ce nom en arabe
deux cents femmes n'attendent avec les
candidats démocrates et républicains li
se porte à la défense des femmes en
citant nul autre que voltaire un érudit
qui avoue ne pas utiliser de montres de
cellulaires d'ordinateurs ni de télé ces
déclarations sont parfois aussi coloré
que ça chemine mois
l'argent c'est comme du fumier
c'est seulement bon quand on les paons
délit dit ce qu'il pense il dévoilera
même sa stratégie politique au grand
jour
intéressant pour certaines mais pas
nécessairement convaincant
c'est l'homme de 69 ans veut-il vraiment
gagner cette course
chose certaine il veut gagner ceci nous
sommes en 11e manche
les cornes de béliers même 2 1 il ya
deux retraits les bus sont remplies
retrait sur trois prises victoire lille
gagnera d'ailleurs le championnat du
vrmo son quatrième entraîneur à sa
manière ce phénomène
m